he's back
okay
hey what's going on there's a police car
in them
what oh
[Music]
oh what's going on oh Phyllis got
flashed it's um
I don't think laughing about it's a
appropriate response oh come on we're
laughing at Phyllis but she's not even
here so no harm no vowel I don't think
the woman in the song incidentally where
were you during all of this maybe you're
the Flasher I said a parent teacher
conference
prove it let's see your penis
I
you know
as that was coming out of my mouth
I knew that it was wrong
feelings is only for pretending to be a
man I'm the real thing sit down on my
lap and there will be no doubt okay no
it's not it's not like penis-wise hello
little boy what's your name Michael it's
me Kevin
Phyllis says I'm too big for her lap oh
I am so sorry that Phyllis hates you and
hates your body but Santa remembers a
reindeer that was just a tiny bit
different as well when can I sit on your
lap right now come on over here big boy
there we go
really comfortable
what would you like for Christmas little
more
I don't know I I didn't know you were
gonna ask me that wow what did you think
was going to happen I didn't know
nobody's ever let me sit on their lap
before
can you give me some choices because I
really don't want to mess up on this
list
what about if I tell you the things I
don't want okay get off get off oh
god I didn't even get to tell you what I
wanted okay you know what you get you
get a thousand helium balloons attached
to you so Santa doesn't have to go
through this again
awesome
damn it
all right who did this
I'm not mad I just want to know who did
it so I can punish them what are you
talking about uh someone uh forged
medical information and that is a felony
okay whoa all right because that's a
pretty intense accusation how do you
know that they're fake ah leprosy
flesh eating bacteria
hot dog fingers
government created killer nano-robot
infection
you did this didn't you absolutely not
yes you did no I didn't I know it was
you okay fine you know what I'm gonna
have to interview each and every one of
you until the perpetrator makes him or
herself known
and until that time
there will be no HealthCare coverage for
anyone
the conference room is ready if we want
to get started you know I just want to
address everyone first oh yeah take your
time Stanley pay attention hi everyone
hi
hi uh look it's no secret hi
hello uh it is no secret
that Michael Scott paper is siphoned off
a large chunk of our Core Business and
I'm here I just want to reassure
everyone that we think this is just a
temporary setback I don't get the big
fuss here I like the site if I had
created a website with this many
problems I'd kill myself do you have a
question Kelly yeah I have a lot of
questions number one how dare you
foreign
has done a very good job
and I am not applauding sarcastically
think about it a month ago nobody would
go on this site because we were worried
about getting molested or losing our
identity having it stolen but now at a
time tdb
all of these problems will be in the
past you've done good kid you're doing
good
all right everybody there has been a lot
of name calling against our office today
corporate maligning slurring much of it
coming from one of you
who claims that prison is better
than here and none of us can say boo
because none of us have ever been to
prison
well
there's somebody I'd like you to meet
somebody else who has been to prison
who can tell you what it is really like
I'm prison Mike
you know why they call me prison Mike do
you really expect us to believe you're
somebody else do you really expect me to
not push you up against the wall
all right hey hey that's just the way we
talk into clink been a lot of fun talk
about prison today but I'm here to scare
you straight
I am in a scary story
in prison you are somebody's
oh and you you my friend would be the
bell of the ball don't drop the soap
don't drop the soap Michael please
where did you learn all of this
internet so not prison and prison at 50
boat look prison stinks is what I'm
saying it's not like you can go home and
recharge your batteries and come back in
the morning and be with your friends
having fun in the office
what'd you do prison Mike
I stole
and I robbed
and I kidnapped the president's son
and held him for a ransom
that is quite the rap sheet prison Mike
and I never got caught neither well
there are prison but um prison Mike what
was the food like in prison gruel
sandwiches
Grill omelets nothing but gruel plus you
can eat your own hair
wow
prison sounds horrible yeah yeah well
thank you Andy thanks prison Mike what's
the very very worst thing about prison
do you encourage him
the worst thing about prison was that
was the Dementors they were flying all
over the place and they were scary and
then they come down and they sucked the
soul out of your body and at height
Dementors like in Harry Potter no not
Harry Potter there are no movies in
prison everyone may have your attention
I would like to introduce you to Mr
Danny cordray he is going to be joining
us as our new traveling salesman say
hello to Danny
me okay you know what no no this is not
some sort of construction site or all of
Italy where you can just go around
treating people like meat we are to
respect him
I respect him because he reminds me of
somebody can anybody guess who that is
Justin Mel yeah I can see that no no no
somebody in this office he's like a
better looking Andy Thanksgiving no me
right
sort of like a little younger version of
me it's hard to judge ourselves
accurately isn't it I am trying had to
be more
optimistic in life
I've got what
20 30 more years left
and my family history says
I have less
now the old Stanley Hudson would have
found something to complain about with
this actress but that's no way to live
life
look at this healthy sexy
pretty strong young woman come on people
she
is
hot
oh help
help what what happened
I fell off the toilet
I'm caught between the toilet and the
wall
what do you need no not you
someone else get Pam I think Pam's going
to want to come into the men's room to
Ryan
oh he needs to lift me and he needs to
clean me up a little bit bring a wet
towel
Ryan is uh dead no he's not dad just saw
him no
okay can you just get up yourself I you
only grilled your foot yeah
oh God